Come on, boys. Come on.
Head up.
Come on, I'm in the lead.
Can you just let me…?
Can you let me win one time?
You've already won,
like, five or six games.
And I'm going easy on you.
No!
-Yes!
-No!
-Mr Ajayi.
-Charlie Spring.
I have a question.
Well, I am officially
a beacon of learning,
so fire away.
How do I stop
liking someone,
specifically a straight guy?
Ah, a question for the ages.
-Hi.
Hi.
You'll be doing the 200
meters for Team Blue,
so you need to be over
by the starting line
in three minutes.
Wait! What?
No!
No protests.
Swap bibs with me.
What? Why?
You hate running,
I'll run it for you.
Happy New Year, Truham Boys!
Don't forget
there might be students
from all school years
in your new form groups.
I hope you enjoy getting
to know some fresh faces
in registration each day.
Hi, sir.
Come to join the ranks
of Hamlet House?
Apparently so.
The guy you sit next to
in form?
Who?
The one that looks
like a golden retriever.
He doesn't look
Okay, he does.
I can't believe
you've been sat next to
rugby king Nick Nelson.
What are you gonna
talk about every morning?
Watching me, please.
With confidence please,
everybody.
Come on!
I am the killer of aliens.
Yes!
I've got it.
Pirates of the Caribbean.
It's a classic.
What do you think?
Yeah.
That sounds good.
Monster Munch?
Yeah, okay.
So, does anyone remember
the rules of rugby?
Because I don't.
No.
Oh, my God!
No, that is a crime.
I cannot believe
you're disrespecting
bubblegum flavour
in front of me.
Right, let me try yours.
-Wow.
-See?
I make good choices.
Is my hair too short?
It looks the same.
But is it okay?
Great, thanks.
Have fun at Nick's.